been a lot of news about Batman coming
out lately and now we got some news
about Joker's we're gonna check out from
emergency awesome the Batman 20:21 new
Joker announced her breakdown and Easter
eggs or bats lost his father now he
dresses in black now if only there was
something we could do to honor this
death with Father's Day coming up oh I
know
titanium matte black wall it's from the
ridge and they have a special sale going
on with Father's Day coming up if you
saw the last fact we plugged rich so if
you saw the last time we plugged rich
you would know that I love the hell out
of this wallet yes we agreed to do it
because I was like yeah I've heard a lot
of people talk about Ridge but after
experiencing the wallet myself I have
never had more conversations about a
wallet in my life like seriously it
feels cool to just whipped out this
wallet it holds up to 12 cards or super
light super durable I genuinely love
this thing thing these things come in
aluminum burnt titanium and carbon fiber
several designs colors to choose from
they're RFID blocking to protect your
info and they've got over 30,000
five-star reviews and the best part is
you can save 10% when you go to ridge
comm slash reject nation and enter our
special promo code reject nation save
yourself ten percent free shipping world
by Searcy rich thank you for sponsoring
this video
[Music]
[Music]
Danny Elfman Betty 99
all right to 95-97 welcome back everyone
it's Charlie this is gonna be my new
Batman video there was a new report that
was published by the direct website
about their plans for a new version of
the Joker direct website Batman trilogy
so we'll bring this actual news what
actual website every website that you
can go to is first number five the
direct website published a report this
past week what to read website to use a
new version of the Joker and his new
Batman trilogy of movies he's going to
use the Joker character way more in a
much bigger way than any previous Batman
movie franchise what I want to hear was
my idea for my a partner series because
there were multiple appearances from
those movie franchises it even though
this better be talking about whether or
not we'll ever see Joaquin Phoenix's
Joker or not another movie they've been
talking about that the Batman to talk
about them not doing it he was great as
that character but Todd Phillips keeps
saying that he never intended for his
Joker movies to crossover with Robert
Pattinson Batman movies you just wanted
to make really good example of previous
Joker's though Heath Ledger only
appeared as the Joker once in the Dark
Knight Jared Leto technically only
appeared in The Suicide Squad film even
though technically he's the version of
the Joker referenced in the birds of
prey movie he never appeared on-screen
during that Jack Nicholson only appeared
in the first Michael Keaton Batman movie
in 1989 fun fact though had they
continued with that iteration of the
Batman franchise in a fifth Batman movie
that would have been titled Batman
Unchained they had planned to bring back
Jack Nicholson title with Jack Nicholson
I think we can all agree though that as
cool as that might have been to see him
come back and reprise his role we were
much better off moving to the
Christopher Nolan Dark Knight trilogy of
Batman films so number for this new
Joker report goes on the state that that
plans for this new version of the Joker
is to cast another major actor there
been a lot of rumors about who that
could be
I'll mention them in a second Bonnie
Joker's story arc in the new Batman
trilogy of movies will be a bigger
version
bigger
of say like the Christopher Nolan Dark
Knight trilogy Joker with Heath Ledger
that's what I wanted the Dark Knight
trilogy treated the Joker character at
the end of Batman Begins Gordon tells
Batman that a new costume crazy person
is serviced and literally is leaving
playing cards as calling cards shows him
the Joker playing card from a recent
crime scene and I just meant to be the
end tag scene teaser that the Joker
would be the main villain of the next
movie The Dark Knight Heath Ledger was
amazing in that but because he
unfortunately passed away before the
Dark Knight Rises was made they opted
not to do any Joker during that third
movie although after he did pass away
Heath Ledger's sisters apparently did an
interview claiming that he had told them
he plan to return in some fashion to the
Dark Knight Rises ah his role would have
been during that movie given that Tom
Hardy's Bane was supposed to be the main
villain if you would have teamed up with
him or just simply taken advantage of
all the chaos that he was causing in
Gotham so number 3 heard of this report
the new Robert Pattinson Batman movie
version of the Joker is supposed to be a
more drawn-out version of the Dark
Knight trilogy version of the Joker
storyline teased him at the end of the
first movie with a reference or a
playing card something small but obvious
letting you know that the Joker exists
within this universe say it didn't I say
that in the last video here on screen in
some fashion during the Batman -
whatever that sequel winds up being but
he wouldn't be the main villain of that
movie like he was during the Dark Knight
he just be a side character in the way
they say like Colin Farrell has said
that his version of the penguin is in
the first Batman movie and has some
great scenes but he's not meant to be
the main villain and he doesn't have a
ton of scenes in terms of quantity
compared to some of the other villains
but they use that second Batman movie to
develop the new Joker character more and
then he becomes the main villain of the
third gasps oh my god you're doing what
I want I did a video last week about how
we're characters like the Riddler and
Catwoman given the success of the
Joaquin Phoenix standalone Joker movie
so there will be more Batman related
movies even if they don't do a 4th
Robert Pattinson Batman movie but number
2 you've also probably seen the rumors
about who might
playing that new version of the Joker
I've seen a lot of recent speculation
about willem dafoe although i think he's
just a fan theory right now more than an
actual possibility Willem Dafoe and
Robert Pattinson just did the lighthouse
movie together a while ago they were a
great pair together
Willem Dafoe is an amazing actor he's
played some amazing villains by
spider-man the Green Goblin in the Tobey
Maguire spider-man movies is still
iconic animation creature spider-man you
and I are not so different but I don't
think that the type of characters that
he typically plays are in the tone of
what Matt Reeves is talking about with
his Batman movie he said that his new
Batman movie are multiple of new movies
if we're talking about a trilogy are
totally somewhere between Tim Burton's
more stylized Batman Christopher Nolan's
more realistic Batman in what I would
call the height reality of the
neo-gothic Batman the Animated Series
the Batman movie this past year you
priced in some of the architecture to
sort of reflects that sort of a little
bit more gothic than what you saw during
Christopher Nolan's Batman movies but
not quite so crazy is what we saw during
the Tim Burton films okay so until they
actually cast someone and we see him on
screen I'm imagining a joker somewhere
between Jack Nicholson's Joker and Heath
Ledger's Joker terrorizes me yes Joaquin
Phoenix would be amazing in the new
Batman movies but I've already done a
couple videos explaining how Todd
Phillips doesn't want his Joker to
crossover with the Batman movies he
seems completely opposed to it the other
news Joker not sure that everyone's been
talking about this year has actually
been Johnny Depp and it's just a rumor
right now I don't know Johnny though is
that a great performance I don't care
who Matt Reeves winds up picking I try
not to have too many expectations like
that because when Heath Ledger was first
announces of the Joker for Dark Knight
the internet just completely hated the
idea cut to a couple years later after
the movie and he became the most beloved
Joker of all time next to Mark Hamill's
Joker I'll tell ya when the chips are
down I bet that comment cause some
problems
it's walking shoe Duke says no who's
checking Phoenix Joker when he was
announced to people freaked out and
suddenly he's now one of the new best
Joker's of all time we're all for today
just cake Cameron Monaghan again
Eckstein different major versions of the
Joker so I'm just gonna do my top 5 in
reverse order here all these are great
purposes by the way starting with Joker
from the very different from the
canonical comic book Joker backstory he
is delivered an iconic performance and
he was my first movie Joker that I ever
saw as a child ever danced with the
devil in the pale moonlight I just like
the sound from the Joker movie however
you feel about the movie itself his
performance was amazing Murray one small
thing yeah
wait bring me out can you introduce me
as Joker and as you probably guessed my
number one pick is actually so it's not
me Heath Ledger Mark Hamill from the
dirt in Mark Hamill's Joker from Batman
the Animated Series normally people only
think about the live-action movies when
you think about the best versions of the
characters but Mark Hamill has one of
the most iconic Joker portrayal in
history from any of the movies any of
the TV series in Beckenham phantasms
relapse itself is one it's okay John
Blair's series in history Batman mask of
the phantasm is also one of the best
Batman movies of all time it just
happens to be an animated movie
do you know is released 1993 yeah okay
you got that right next year after we
hopefully get to watch this thing Batman
movie I will agree ranked my new Batman
movie tier list but post all your
reactions in the comments below who do
you want to play this new version of the
Joker and who is your favorite or Salva
Michael B Jordan pretty much but leave
all your requests in the comments below
everyone click here for my other brow
movies and clicking for that brand new
Bill and Ted face the music trailer
thank you so much for watching you must
be Harvey squeeze yeah I love this idea
if any of this is to be believed or true
I've said this in the last year that I
was like you should have Joker be a
presence let his existence be known and
then have him built to be the ultimate
villain in part 3 89s Batman
the first villain and that Batman
franchise was Joker and the second
Batman franchise Nolan's part two Dark
Knight was Heath Ledger's and then you
could really build them up and in this
new franchise have the heart three be
the Joker villain I like the idea
even if there's like a little bit of
Joker in the second movie I imagine that
this trilogy goes well they'll probably
want to continue it expand it not just
be a solid three I just don't feel you
can do a like really cover the Batman
mythos and mythology in the whole world
of Batman and all the trolls yeah its
coverage there's no way you can really
do that so if they want to build the bat
burst like they talked about in last
video I get that I've always wanted a
specific eight part Batman movie where
you start off where he's younger and you
have them go into like Old Man Batman
like Frank Miller's Dark Knight Returns
era I thought it would be neat if you
did have Joker in it throughout what
we're hearing from these reports
especially in the sense of like yeah
pain will be here but he won't be the
main villain in this one and the same
thing with hearing about
the possibility of what they would want
to do a joker hearing that it sounds
like what Matt Reeves is doing in some
way I'm not saying this is exactly what
he's doing there's a version of this
that can be likened to bringing the
animated series to life where the world
is already very much lived in because if
you look at most of these superhero
movies the Batman movies included it's
usually like new villain in town we got
to take him down new villain in town
we've got to take him down and maybe
there will be some of that but it seems
like for the most part it's gonna start
off and continue as something that's
already lived in and maybe some of the
main villains or whoever the main
villain is in each installment will
already be someone who Batman is
familiar with already as opposed to new
baddie in town gotta fight him get his
origin tale okay you know what I mean
well that's the thing is is you think
back to the cartoon especially the
comics you have villains shuffling in
and out of Arkham and it seems like in
in those forms of the story the villains
are more a community than just yeah like
one guy who rolls into town gets taken
care of it is replaced or something yeah
so to have a movie that utilizes that
sense of universe I think would be
really smart because it's not quite as
sprawling as doing like a whole MCU but
it's also leaving you open to a lot of
options and a lot of cross-pollination
and yeah a lot of room to have villains
appear and stuff so yeah like you said I
would love to see the Joker pop up or at
least be a presence in the second movie
that is only looming and doesn't ever
just fully take hold until part three
and that would be an appropriate
build-up and all that and I just loved
the sound of this too because the tone
he's going for I love what Christopher
Nolan did but it is very grounded and
then that inspired every other movie
that came after that to try and be very
grounded for a while and I think this is
a great concept because you know clearly
that brought the weight that those
movies can punch but what I have started
to miss is that more Tim burton-esque
heightened more gothic more again
inspired by the craziness of the comics
type of world and so I love the idea of
fusing those together heightening it
back up a little bit especially in the
scenery because one thing I know we've
talked about over the course of the
years and reviewing these new or DC
Batman movies and stuff is the feeling
of Gotham as a character and one thing
especially about the older films and you
know even the Schumacher ones say what
you will at this city is
very much a character akin to the comics
and maybe like Batman Begins kind of got
there again a little bit but yeah I love
what they're pitching here and I think
it's the right idea I mean we've talked
plenty about like what other people
could play Joker Garrett Hedlund get him
in there Sam Worthington now rank those
guys okay
I think Willem Dafoe though I don't
really agree with the assessment that if
you were to be casting it that there's
his style of acting would in NASH we
don't exactly know it's kind of going
off of everything established but will
him to [ __ ] him blend into almost any
genre yes I mean he can be really
heightened if the role calls for it but
he can dial it back if he needs to oh
yes a very talented actor and the thing
about him is he's a little bit timeless
even though he is older yeah but yeah
like his age as never he's always looked
weird yeah so it would still maybe work
over a couple movies even the ages
emergency also spent a long time on the
ranking here of the Joker portrayals you
know honestly I agree you guys might
have seen the videos in the past one
Joaquin Phoenix's Joker came up and
granted absolutely deserve the Oscar but
in terms of Joker villain criminal
mastermind or akin to the comics I got
to give it a Heath Ledger I do and Mark
Hamill's is certainly iconic you know it
would be cool to see if he did do a
live-action one day maybe in one of the
CW shows and that's not the media most
people of water but anybody maybe in one
of the CW shows because that seems like
the best place where you get the
opportunity considering Kevin Conroy did
it on crisis on Infinite Earths as
iconic as it is audience association
with it is really with the voice in
terms of performance I would still give
it to heat the ledger because a lot goes
into acting with you know body language
of manner Ottomans which I'm sure Mark
Hamill is doing in the voice booth it
would be cool to see it done in real
life he's play the trickster on the
flash and that's probably the closest we
can see to really capturing some Joker
isms in terms of live-action performance
from the guy the fan casting maybe a lot
of names aren't out for a very long time
I hope Matt Reeves continues to do the
choices that are like wooden I expected
that but that
that seems to be what a lot of the
casting has been I don't want bill
skarsgård a lot of people are he's done
penny wise Doug laughing yeah he's done
the clown thing already though Johnny
Depp would be fine actually
if he cares I feel like he would be fine
I really have no idea more more looking
forward to it tom Felton there you go
Matt Reeves connection yes I'm back from
Planet of the Apes all right guys what
do you think about all this Joker news
who's your favorite Joker and now that
Joker 2019 has had almost no cousin like
five more months or something until it's
a whole year how would you rank your
Joker's let me know down below make sure
to subscribe emergency awesome if you
haven't done so already subscribe to the
real rejects click that notification
well again notified whenever got a video
well hit that like button if you enjoyed
this video thanks Ridge for sponsoring
this video last but not least Jay T
three days ago
June 7th was JT's birthday and like good
old-fashioned Greg always late to
wishing people happy birthday just like
in real life with all my friends
hmm I have a wonderful reputation but JT
I just wanted to say to you happy
birthday happy birthday to you
[Music]
in addition
happy Hannukah
let's get nuts